GO SO, LIZ CHENEY IS FROM
NORTHERN VIRGINIA, AND SOMEHOW
FOUND OUT THAT THE ONLY OTHER
MEMBER OF CONGRESS -- FROM
WYOMING.
IT IS INTERESTING IS -- SHE
DECIDED TO SPEND HER TIME IN
CONGRESS REPRESENTING SOMETHING
CALLED DEMOCRACY.
>> EVERYONE OF US WHO HAS SWORN
THE OATH MUST ACT TO PREVENT THE
UNRAVELING OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> ON -- UNDERSTANDING THE
PERILS OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> DEMOCRACY IS FRAGILE.
DEMOCRACY IS FRAGILE.
DEMOCRACY ONLY SURVIVES IF
CITIZENS ARE WILLING TO DEFEND
IT.
>> IT TURNS OUT THAT DEMOCRACY
IS LIKE THE BOYFRIEND YOU HAVE
IN ANOTHER CITY: UTAH COME UP A
LOT AND DON'T WANT HIM TO SHOW
UP IF YOU CAN EVEN MEET HIM, BUT
I THINK DEMOCRACY SHOWED UP IN
WYOMING.
THAT WAS THE SINK'S
--
THAT WAS THE BIGGEST SINGLE
DEFEAT OF AN INCUMBENT --
WHAT'S FUNNY IS THAT OVER AT
CNN, THEY ARE STILL DEFENDING
DEMOCRACY, BUT THEY HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT IT IS.
TURNS OUT, DEMOCRACY MEANS "YOU
SHUT UP AND SUBMIT TOOL OF THE
PEOPLE HAVE NOT BEEN ELECTED,
AND IN THE CASE OF LIZ CHENEY --
AND FOR HER, IT'S THAT PEOPLE
SHE REPRESENTS -- DON'T LIKE
HER.
>> ON WYOMING, AND WHAT HAPPENS
THERE, COULD ADD TO A TREND.
THAT IS ELECTION DENIERS WINNING
PRIMARIES AROUND THE NATION.
>> THAT IS -- JANUARY 6TH.
[LAUGHTER]
>> WHEN VOTERS REJECT THE
CANDIDATE THAT CNN LIKE, THE
VOTERS VOTE, WHICH IS OF COURSE,
THE CORE RITUAL OF DEMOCRACY.
WHEN THEY DO THAT, IT'S A THREAT
TO DEMOCRACY.
DEFINITIVELY IN WYOMING, THAT'S
THE GREATEST THREAT TO DEMOCRACY
SINCE THE CIVIL WAR.
SHE SHOULD KNOW THAT
TECHNICALLY --
>> THE GREAT AND ORIGINAL
CHAMPION OF OUR PARTY WAS
DEFEATED IN THE ELECTIONS FOR
THE SENATE AND --
WHERE HE WON THE MOST IMPORTANT
ELECTION OF ALL.
HE DEFINED OUR OBLIGATION AS
AMERICANS FOR ALL OF HISTORY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> LINCOLN LOGS, I AM LINCOLN.
ANOTHER SAD RIC